hello everyone welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics rationally what is
rational everybody thinks they're
rational now the way we do it in science
we Define the word rational and if you
meet the criteria then you are
rational and if you don't like the
definition
you have only one option and that is to
Define it better come up with a better
mouse trap so how do we Define rational
well we usually Define it in the
negative like irrational irrational
means the primarily in physics to have a
theory that uh involves the movement of
Concepts okay if you're going to move a
concept you're going to move love around
you know you're going to move
intelligence around well then you don't
have much of a theory it's not of a
physical Theory okay and that's
essentially what we have today a lot of
movement of love and
intelligence what we have today is the
movement of um mathematical Concepts
they uh transfer energy they move the
mass they wave the
wave and that's what it's all about the
movement of mathematical Concepts those
are the physical interpretations we have
today anyways couple uh fellows made a
comment about arthritis that I told them
I have arthritis my hands my shoulders
elbows and so on they said one fell says
what is arthritis arthritis is when your
metabolism is hindered by your nutrition
and your body stores the wrong chemicals
in your joints uhhuh the metabolism only
works properly again when you stop
eating the wrong food then the stored
chemicals are ex excreted it uh works
all by itself you don't need to do
anything other than stop eating certain
foods or drinks I have experienced it
myself so F says that or believes that
this has to do with eating you eat the
wrong stuff you're going to get
arthritis uhuh another F says arthritis
is inflammation okay uh you need to take
dietary supplements that reduce
inflammation and avoid foods that give
you inflammation okay do it as soon as
possible before arthritis deforms your
limbs
uh we have lots of doctors out there
everybody's a doctor
today you don't need to go to the doctor
just consult one of these guys they'll
tell you what to do uh yeah what can I
tell you uh I think there's a propensity
for different people because of their
genetics the way they're born you know
toh have certain uh maladies uh
illnesses disorders whatever you want to
call them um and some people have ATT
tenden like me to have arthritis you
know as far as I know I was the only guy
in the family with arthritis maybe I'm
wrong I don't know um and I think a lot
of it has to do with uh genetics but you
know I was born with a tendency other
people are born with a tendency for
diabetes others for cancer you know and
I got stuck with this stuff uh but I
think the way out of it is uh not so
much eating yeah eating
obviously must help somehow okay I'll
just say that but I think uh the main
thing is exercise you exercise you won't
have trouble uh but if you don't do
exercise uh and uh you eat the wrong
stuff then Mother Nature will punish you
no M no doubt about that okay okay so uh
I'm G to go ahead with some ether stuff
we haven't closed all the uh Lo we
haven't tied all the knots you know and
um we've had some people who uh I've
given homework too out there all the
eist and I was hoping that one of them
would come out and say look let me let
me tell you what the ether is or let me
draw for it you uh The Ether right
because if you can illustrate The Ether
right or Define the word then I know
what you're talking about but if you
don't Define it or illustrate it well I
have no clue whatsoever what you're
talking about what do you mean by Ether
whenever you mention the word and so
this is the whole problem the whole
problem these people start talking in
the middle of the uh you know they start
uh the uh their theories in the middle
of the film and they start talking about
the ether as if you knew what it was and
then they said this is my theory and
they start with a theory no I don't want
you to tell me your theory I want you to
illustrate The Ether or if if it's an a
physical object
or Define it if it's an abstract concept
okay either one I don't care but you
have to tell me what the ether is
according to you and what these people
say usually is you know the uh they give
you the U old
um uh what is it um it's a mantra they
have really that they have for God you
know if I knew what God looks like or
what he is then he wouldn't be so great
you know and uh these people say more or
less the same thing for The Ether you
know if if I knew what the ether was
then it wouldn't be so invisible so uh
so powerful it wouldn't underly every
underly everything out out there in the
universe they would just uh come in
there and uh you know that's why they go
directly to the theory because they
cannot tell you what the the what the
ether is this is the whole problem and
yeah an eist like I Define it all the
time is a person who doesn't know what
the ether is that's the definition
defition of an ether and so here was the
this fellow uh the other day and this is
what he put up there uh he says I was
going to draw for you The Ether but nah
you would still find something negative
to say why would I even bother your
nuts okay yeah he said he couldn't draw
The Ether uh also because he wasn't a
good illustrator good artist or whatever
and so he just ran away with a tail
between his legs
okay so we have this F he just ran away
he didn't come back to tell us what the
ether is I guess uh and he's well to
come come back and tell us what the
ether is very simple you know I mean uh
the doors are open just tell us what the
ether is illustrate it whatever you need
to do okay another fell he uh he said
the following the other day he said
ether would be like the seed of an apple
uhuh there is your object a seed you
know and there I have Johnny apple seed
you know planting a seed and from there
I guess something grows I don't know uh
the world the universe and so yeah we
have this situation where uh I showed uh
Neil turak and uh Steven Hawking they
came up in 1999 they uh published an
article essentially they were uh
interviewed by astronomy magazine and
they came up with this the one in the
center there they said it looks like a
pee which is very much like this
fellow's seed you could say right and uh
so you know that's what they call it
they say it's the P instanton okay and I
think this was primarily Neil tur's
um idea but I guess Hawking stood behind
it and uh this is what it looks like
this is how Neil I guess uh um
illustrates it you know there you have
the open Universe The Singularity the
whole works all all there okay and all
the steps from The Big Bang onwards but
uh the pan ston was out there first okay
and that was what the big Bank how the
big Bank started okay that's the
starting point so what is this uh
starting point this P how did it get
there well they don't tell you that they
don't tell you what's outside of it what
gives it shape you know like in this
case the white stuff that gives shape to
the PE instanton you know so we don't
know what that white stuff is that gives
shape to it we don't know where it came
from you know did God make this or what
you know I mean you got to tell us a
little bit more than just say there's
your pee you know yeah what can I do
with it and that's the same problem with
this ether IST who says you know it
looks like a pee and that or seed in his
case right and so here it is uh this is
what he says this this is how he back it
up he says the ether is eternal uhuh
sounds like God already right all
objects are of The Ether although the
ether is not any object uhuh so here we
are he's saying essentially you know uh
your table is made of atoms but the atom
is not a thing it's not an object so we
have a thing made out of something which
is not a thing that's more or less what
he's saying there he's saying the ether
is not an object object but it makes up
everything else that is an object okay
so that's what he's saying ether is not
a particle although particles are of The
Ether
perturbed and that is why they vibrate
and have frequency waves The Ether has
no space no cartisan therefore it is not
visible okay so I guess he's excusing
why why he can't uh draw it but then he
says it's a seed so there on the lower
left you can see the seed Johnny apple
seed planting a seed so he says it's a
seed that's what it looks like but he
says it's invisible and I guess that's I
had to draw it for him he didn't draw it
I drew it for him right okay so he says
looks like a seed or maybe the Panton or
who knows what okay and then he says he
clarifies says objects are not falling
towards each other in gravity uhuh they
are accelerating towards the null point
that is the return Vector to ether as
pure potential
ether what is ether the it's pure
potential then he says space is the loss
of the ether's pure potential uhhuh
space is not a thing but the absence of
a thing well yeah you can't Define
things in the negative you can't use an
antonym to define a thing in science
okay you got or or a synonym right you
you can't say a dog is not a horse well
yeah no kidding you know what is it not
a tree also not not a rock okay you
going to go through every word in the
dictionary and say it's a it's not that
it's not the other one you know no we
can't Define in terms of negatives and
so he hasn't told us anything when he
says it's not a thing because we don't
know what a thing is according to him uh
especially when he says that the ether
is pure potential and then he continues
he says the seed is a much better
example for The Ether than your thread/
rope object
ahuh okay okay he says just like the
seed its potential is lost as a tree
that grows and then bears fruit which
returned back to Pure potential seed
okay and why do you keep returning to
the particle luminiferous ether Theory
which is wrong and
say uh see this is wrong so where're so
there is no
ether uh yeah well I can tell you what
everybody in their mother thinks the
luminiferous ether is okay it's not a
theory it's called a hypothesis it's an
assumption and the assumption is that
there is uh this loner ether out there
it's made of particles gazillions of
particles some people say that it's
equal to space that space and ether are
synonyms others say The Ether is
contained within space but that's what
it's always been a whole bunch of
particles and so you're the first one
who says that it's a seed first of all
you probably are the only person on
Earth that's say is a seed but you're
you're not saying it's a seed you're
just saying it's pure potential and
potential is a concept there's no such
thing as potential and you can't say
that everything is made of potential
that's irrational that's what it's
called irrational so you found out just
now that you're an irrational
individual okay you know you don't have
a case you don't have a leg to stand on
so so far we have no illustration of
what the ether is and certainly it
cannot be a seed because nobody you
can't do anything what are you going to
do move the seed around what's outside
the seed space I mean you know what is
the seed and that's when he goes into
poetry and says well it's pure
potential you know well you got to lay
off the uh drugs the
shrooms okay another fellow says says
here what did he say here says he going
to prove these
says first ether is you just need to
Define what you're envisioning totally
agree you got to define the word if
that's what it is a concept objects we
point to and illustrate or show the
shape and Concepts we Define so he says
Define it okay if it's a concept then
you have to Define it no doubt about
that it seems most great physics ideas
come from a creative spark internally
which must be externalized by tools like
math weird right no we don't need math
at all here has nothing to do with math
you either show us a picture of it and
point to it in which case we don't need
any math or you define a word in which
case we don't need any math either we
don't need math to to know what the
ether is okay if it's even if it's an a
mathematical concept you can always
Define it with words you don't need math
okay you don't need quantities here the
idea is often uh the idea often comes
first then is proven no in science we
don't prove that's in religion where
they prove proof means that you convince
someone of something and now he believes
it strongly because belief is just
belief you know opinion and proof you
know knowledge means that you believe it
more strongly that's all it means but
you still believe it how did Plato
Define knowledge he said justified
through belief that's what knowledge is
just belief and Justified true are both
opinions whatever is Justified whatever
is true is just an opinion what's true
to you is a lie to your neighbor so all
we had was opinions all these years for
the word
knowledge hell one could almost say has
concept of ether has been actualized by
the discovery of electrons which exist
virtually everywhere yeah electrons
atoms you know no electrons don't exist
everywhere you have the atoms in between
them and neutrons and who knows what so
no no to say that electrons are
everywhere you haven't solve the problem
you're not what are you saying that uh
all ether is just a bunch of beads which
is really my definition of The Ether
because it is a concept yeah ether bunch
of particles you want to call them
electrons okay bunch of electrons no
problem but the issue is what are we
going to do with that and what's giving
shape to each uh electron what's uh
what's containing all this because if
the electron is a little bead I'm
assuming that's what you're referring to
then it's got to be contained by
something that gives it background and
you got to identify that background what
is it space and now you got to tell us
what space is you know so it's on and on
and on until you get your hypothesis
until you get your assumptions down you
know pth that we have to understand the
whole picture before you go to your
theory and you said well we don't know
now knowledge has nothing to do with
science and science we don't use the
word knowledge they use it in religion
knowledge means Justified true
belief and belief has to do solely
with
religion uh so that's not a well-rounded
Theory well-rounded means knowledge
again means that uh you've proven
something meaning that you believe it
that's all it is so that's all that
grounded means we don't ground anything
in science we give an assumption we make
an assumption and the other person has
to to take it at face value in order to
understand the theory so you have to be
clear on your assumption what are you
proposing before you start your theory
and then you can go on and explain your
theory your mechanism your what caused
it or whatever right the
phenomena often paired with mud flood
and Flat Earth okay I don't know what
that's all about it's not a tall order
that's where concrete definitions of
things before trying to what prove them
we don't prove anything in science so uh
this well has to take um kindergarten
uh physics physics 101 first you know
know what the scientific method is even
that's earlier science
101 okay so um let's get on with these
other issue so we'll finish there with
ether we'll see if some of these guys
come over and uh give us an idea of what
the ether is and by what I mean mean
draw it illustrate it if you can't
illustrate it or you say it's not a
thing it's an object you know a body a
medium good if it's not that then it's a
concept then you have to define the word
very simple you know so all ethers are
welcome to take that homework and come
here when they have it
completed okay let's move on to uh our
other issue here and that is the uh
subject of today and we're going to be
doing a little bending of light we're
going to use Mass okay but first we're
going to begin with um with a bending of
light that does not involve
Mass which is strange because you know
in one scenario they use mass and in the
other one they do not use Mass they use
something called defraction or like in
this case this spell refraction okay and
so you have uh these Two Worlds the
microscopic world where they do not
introduce uh mass and you have the macro
world the general relativity strength
Theory as well where they introduce Mass
so we have the mass and the mass Lov
okay so let's begin with the Massa so
that you can get a start getting in you
know into the uh hang of thing get the
hang of things so you see what's how
they treat these subjects we're going to
go with a massless verse here it is and
it's got to do with this you know uh the
other day I mentioned that um uh you
know you had this uh balloon you know
that the astronaut carries to to space
and the balloon pops okay the balloon
pops and the air comes out we colorcoded
it so that you could see it okay and so
we want to say the only thing the only
thing we want to say about that is does
that blob have shape or not it's a yes
or or no type of question it's not what
is the shape of a blob no that's not the
question the question is does a blob
have shape okay that's the question okay
it's a yes or no type of question these
fellows one one guy and another they
went and drifted out and talking about
you know where the the last atom and how
does it flow and stuff that really was
irrelevant to the subject matter that we
discussed and so here you see it says if
a balloon in space pops right what is
the movement pattern of the gas released
from the balloon he's talking about the
movement of the gas well who cares I
mean I don't care that wasn't the issue
the issue was does that have shape does
that blob of air to the last atom there
right in the blob that's expanding right
does that blob have shape and the answer
hopefully is yes if you have eyes right
in fact even if you don't have eyes it
does have shape by definition okay does
it move around like a small cloud or or
does it disperse outwards like the
hypothetical Big Bang or what would it
be does a gas hold itself together or
disperse into molecules well gases tend
to expand and I think that's what this
other fellow answered he says to to him
answered him liquids and gases take the
form shape of the container absolutely
not okay absolutely not the air molecule
inside of a balloon would be moving at
roughly the speed of sound or slightly
faster no we do not need a container to
give shape to things and this is a big
misunderstanding misconception that
people have out there and again here
we're going to take the astronaut back
up there because people seem to have
problems understanding this you know
we're going to take um what is it a gas
any gas in this case I called it air you
can call it whatever you want you know
uh you want to use uh I don't know
something a gas uh what you know like
argon or whatever it doesn't matter just
color coded so that we know what we're
talking about the balloon goes out there
the the Astron goes out there with a
balloon he's got some gas inside that
balloon okay and so far it's got the
shape of the balloon whatever gas is in
there he pops the balloon and out comes
the gas okay it's colorcoded we can now
see it it has shape and so the only
issue is does that white stuff that you
see on the third uh frame of the film
right does that have shape and hopefully
the answer is yes for anyone you know
and you say well what is the shape of
that well no it's a blob so it's got
blob shape okay we don't care what the
shape of it is the issue is does it have
shape and hopefully the answer is yes so
does the pop balloon by the way they
both have shape okay so uh you don't
need a container because space is not a
container and you can see it has shape
despite not having a container okay so
this balloon is expanding
I'm sorry the gas is expanding and we
don't care if it's expanding or not we
take a snapshot at a given point in time
right and hopefully something comes out
in the picture that you took okay so
yeah it does have shape it's got blob
shape and we don't care what the shape
of it is we're just saying it does have
shape therefore that whole thing that
whole blob is known as an object as a
thing hopefully anything made out of
atoms is a um you know is a thing
okay so I think it's straightforward I
mean I don't know what kind of problem
people might have in understanding what
I'm saying I'm I think this is
straightforward unless you have some
kind of mental block and can't uh
conceptualize what I'm trying to tell
you here you know okay uh here's one
fell and he's struggling to understand
what an object is so yeah some people
are struggling and I'm sorry for all
those of you who understand it already
but I've got to go through with some of
these folks because they're having
trouble understanding something as
simple as what is an object what is a
thing what is a medium right what is an
agent and here it is well it says I'm
manufacturing jawbreakers in space it
has a hole in the center that was made
in the vacuum of outer space okay we
bring it back down to earth okay we
bring it down to earth the hole has the
form shape of its container sphere
Circle yeah it could be a cube doesn't
matter so he thinks that it has the hole
itself
has shape because it's trapped within
the container and so the hole has the
shape of the container if it was a cubic
container the hole would be you know
cubic and if it's a spherical one the
hole would be spherical that's that's
what he's got in this poor you know
that's what he's thinking that's the way
thinking I guess you can call it
thinking lack of thinking right is the
hole an object of course not and yeah we
agree there the hole is not an object
but why isn't it an object okay and here
we have uh let's see if Bugs Bunny can
teach us a lesson today okay here we
have Bugs Bunny okay he's in the middle
of nowhere okay and I guess out in the
field
somewhere and uh you can see that he's
in a hole the hole is dark black you
could say let's call it black okay and
he's in the middle of a field and he's
just sitting there right with his arm on
the ground but does the hole have shape
that's the question and a lot of people
would say well yeah the hole has shape
like a shadow has shape right and the
answer is no what has shape is the
ground okay and so uh just so that you
don't get confused let's remove the
ground okay we're going to remove the
ground okay and find out the hole has
shape and here it is that's what was
underneath uh the ground we took the
ground we put good old uh bugs out there
in space and you can see that you know
the hole disappeared there was no hole
okay what was there was ground not hole
okay and let's show it again one more
time here it is there's good old bugs
right and he's just sitting there right
and people think that the hole has shape
and it doesn't you know it's got to be a
standalone thing and here let me show
you what I'm talking about here we have
an angel right with a what is is known
as a Halo usually a plate or a ring
around his head okay and the question is
you know is there a difference between a
Halo and a rain and yeah the answer is
yes a Halo is not an object because it's
a dependent object much like uh in the
case of Bug's hole you know the ground
served as the object and people confused
the hole with the ground they think both
of them are objects and no the the
object was the ground not the hole okay
and here we have a more or less the same
situation the Halo is a depend object
you could say you know just to talk in
those terms it's not really an object
but it's a concept because the Halo has
the Hol built into it it's a holy ring
and a holy ring is not a ring a holy
ring is a concept okay if we remove the
angel like you see on the right all we
have is the ring okay we don't have the
angel anymore so that's a standalone
object and we call it a ring the other
one is not a standalone object because
in order to call it a Halo we had better
have the angel
underneath okay so that's the issue and
so yeah in the case of bugs the hole is
not the object the object if you go far
back you will see the shape of the
ground and the ground looks like a donut
that's what it is it's got a hole in
it's a donut okay or whatever maybe a
cube with a circle in it but the hole is
not the object the object is the you
know the we'll call it the dut right
that's the object and we prove this very
simple by getting rid of the dut and see
if the hole remains and you'll find out
that the hole is a dependent object
meaning it's a concept like the Halo it
depends on the donut without the donut
no ho very simple okay for some
people for intelligent people okay and
uh F says here the following he says uh
with a art you can Force the AI to
illustrate vacuum of space ether and all
those hog bash fake things
metaphysicians believe in yeah with some
of this technology like Chad GPT and so
on uh you can start questioning a lot of
stuff that mathematical physics has
proposed over the last 100 years because
now you can feed it to the chat GPT and
he'll you know this robot will give you
an answer and the question what are you
going to put for you know transfer
energy uh I mean you can program some of
these things and say well if you program
energy as a physical object some kind of
smoke or whatever you want to put in
there cloud and you say I transfer
energy the computer understands that but
if you are very careful with your
language and you say you transfer energy
but you do not
illustrate uh the chat GPT the computer
will not know what to transfer you know
what are they going to transfer you got
to put something for the energy if
you're going to give the computer a an
instruction to transfer something and I
think you can put a lot of the stuff
into chat GPT you know a lot of the
concepts that they're transferring and
you know wave the wave what are you
waving a bunch of vectors you know you
have vectors you know magnitude and
Direction transverse wave what are you
going to put you know unless you draw it
then then the computer will know what
the transf say I'm transferring this
this bunch of arrows that the computer
understands but then you have to be
careful careful that you're staring at a
bunch of vectors and not arrows not
engine arrows you know so and so he says
the AI won't explain to you how it works
though maybe Chad GPT will try to
explain mechanisms to you but we'll end
up parting the usual bad arguments of
modern theoretical physic yeah one of
the problems there is a lot of the stuff
are is programmed by the mathematical
physicist and programmers who learned
the same nonsense in college right and
so yeah uh he ends up saying at this
point it's better to argue with AI than
with these people the things they write
read like AI
anyway yeah so uh all I can tell you is
that u a lot of these
people uh they program the chat gpts the
robots the AIS all that stuff and they
just put in there what is the worldly
wisdom which comes from mathematical
physics but I challenge them to transfer
energy to move the mass to wave the wave
to shake the field you know and uh what
are you going to put you got to draw
something for the computer to understand
it it's got to be an object it's got to
have shape then you can wave the you can
excite the field move the mass transfer
energy then you can do that but if you
don't put an object there what will the
computer understand what will it shake
what will it move what will it transfer
and that's what you got to think
about okay uh let's get on with this
issue of the
um uh what is it of the
[Music]
um what was it I lost my head for a
second here uh the mass the mass bending
light and what we have is that again uh
we have a um situation where you have
some of these experiments with they bend
light they do it without mass and those
are all in quantum mechanics in the
world of the small and in the world of
the big they have something else they
have mass doing it because that's all
that a mathematical physicist talks
about just Mass out there everything in
in the universe just mass and gravity
they never
discovered uh magnetism you know the
magnetic fields of stars of galaxies
they of planets they never discovered
that all these uh celestial objects as
we call them um have magnetic fields so
they do everything with mass everything
is done with mass and gravity uh Dark
Matter gravity uh black hole gravity you
know mass and gravity and so on
everything is done with mass and gravity
even the big bang you know it's that
expansion you know which is being pushed
or fueled by dark energy what is that
Mass and gravity what is
uh Dark Energy it's the opposite of Dark
Matter one pulls the other one pushes so
one is gravity which is dark matter and
dark energy is what opposes it's the
anti-gravity is pushing everything away
from concentration so it's it's all done
with gravity and so no one has ever in
mathematical physics discovered
uh magnetism you know they they don't
think magnetism plays any role out there
so what can I tell you okay uh that's a
big Omission that they have there okay
so here we have it uh we're going to
start with the Massa stuff and we'll
start here with a needle experiment okay
and F says the following says the needle
experiment is an
insignificant is as insignificant as the
double slit experiment both are very
easy to explain okay great light is not
a wave and never was and that's how he
starts his presentation he said he gives
me a link and I go see the link see what
it's all about but before that I need to
clarify what he's talking about what is
this needle experiment okay so let's
start there we have uh Thomas Young 1802
and 1803 he did some experiments in his
uh dark basement okay and he found out
uh what is known today as the double
slit experiment we have two slits you
monochromatic light through through
these slits and he produced fringes on
the wall and that was kind of strange
because you would think that if light
goes through two slits you would get two
slits on the wall that's not what he got
he got fringes and there you see the
double slit experiment with slits and
then it turns out he did it also with a
hair and he acknowledged Newton he said
that Newton did that he pulled the hair
out of his head I guess and did this uh
experiment where he shown some light
allowed some light to pass through a
little slid or or some enter the room a
dark room and he found that the hair
also produced fringes okay and it's very
important to distinguish between the one
on the left the slit the double slit
there and the one on the right the hair
okay very important and we're going to
see why now in a minute okay so uh here
is Bill's needle experiment okay and
you'll see why or how we explain it in
um in rational science okay we have
needle and we're saying that every atom
of the flashlight or the the laser
pointer whatever you're going to use
there um every atom there okay is
connected already to the needle
especially to the atoms at the sides on
the sides of the needle that make up the
sides the edges of the needle and every
atom there is also connected to every
atom on the screen on on the back wall
okay so what happens is you have
interference patterns uh and you can see
there the pattern and it shows okay
there all these are interwined there
okay so what you have is um differences
in um in uh the length of the links of
the ropes that make up the mediator of
light okay that's what you have and you
can see it on the far right there in the
hair experiment you can see that all
these are offset and because of that you
have either uh constructive interference
where you see the bright bands and uh
destructive interference in between in
between the bands okay so there it is
that's how simple it is with a rope
model okay no major problem there okay
hopefully everybody understands everyone
who's been doing U wave we're replacing
the wave with a rope we're saying uh
light is a rope rope okay or it's
mediated by a rope what you have is a
situation if you you can simulate it
with your hands okay you've got your
hands together and as soon as you move
sideways okay you can see they're offset
okay see what happens to my hands that's
what's happening one rope is now one
link or a quarter of Link or whatever
amount behind the other one they're not
you know when they're together you have
constructive interference and here you
have destructive and so on down the line
and so that's why you get the fringes
and and that's been you know I didn't
come up with this uh this came up from
the wave nature of light they already
had discovered that okay and uh all
we're doing is replacing the wave which
is a mathematical concept with the rope
and with a rope you can explain it rope
is a thing it's a thing that you know
now is torquing there and it's just
either um constructive meeting the uh
another rope right there at that same
point or the offset by half a link or
whatever and that's what's happening
very simple okay what's the problem with
particles which is what this fell is
going to propose well here it is this is
the problem okay here you see it okay
and this is something that uh by the way
uh let me show this first okay here we
have good old Einstein and Neils bore
and in 1927 at the SV conference they
had the this this discussion this was
right there this was what the fight was
all about between them and the issue was
the slid experiment and what was the
problem the problem was that uh they
were simulating it with particles okay
and they said well what happens when
when you shoot a particle you know when
when you point the laser pointer at the
slits right it would move the whole
partition sideways and so you would have
you would not know you know the exact
position of you know of the of the beam
because of the photon really because it
hit supposedly it hit the uh partition
you know the one that contained the uh
slits and it would move it already there
was some amount of motion a very tiny
imperceptible motion but but that's what
bore was saying you cannot determine
both the position and the motion of the
particle this was Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle and so Einstein
tried to get around that by saying oh if
we shoot you know the we do the the uh
uh slit experiment with a laser point or
whatever with a light Etc and Neils bore
you know just trumped them and said no
you can't because the photon will hit
the partition and move it and now you
don't know the position and the exact
motion of the photon that's going to go
to the uh screen that was the whole
issue that was what the fight was about
so here we see it let me show you this
again now here we see it you see uh this
is simulated by someone else I just
stole it from them just to show you you
know what what we've got here what you
see there's a light source and it shoot
shoots a photon it's also been done with
electrons and they're shooting it
against the uh the slit the outside of
It's banging against the frame which is
called I looked it up it's called a jam
uh the jam is the two lines uh vertical
lines that form the screen the frame of
the slits okay so they got these jams
okay so they have this these lines there
it hits the edge of the jam right and
then the particle goes there and
interferes with the one from the other
side that's how they try to explain it
with particles uh the trick here is or
the the problem with it really is that
uh the particle has to be at two places
at once because the particle is only one
particle is shot out but it's at two
places at once at the two um jams right
the two sides of the uh slits and then
they interfere when they hit the screen
that's how they try to explain some
people try to explain it this way okay
they have other explanations as well but
what what they have is they hit they
have the the ball the photon has to hit
the jam has to hit the frame or the sill
or whatever okay it's got to hit there
so what happens uh this what happens why
we need the needle because we get rid of
the slits okay and here it is you see
what's happening there now okay you're
going to see in a second here instead of
hitting the we get rid of the uh slit we
just leave something in the center we're
going to call it the needle there it is
we only have a needle there okay there's
the needle now what's it going to hit
against okay how's it how come it's
going to come inwards if it has no Jam
no frame to hit against and bounce
inwards see now the photon just goes
straight
ahead and now we can't get that Photon
to turn the corner that's the problem
okay so this is the
issue okay and U so here you see it okay
this F says light particles explain rect
linear propagation and reflection and no
it doesn't because uh the sun actually
you know shoots particle in every
direction uh from every uh atom in the
sun is uh and this according to Quantum
right shoots uh photons it creates these
uh light particles particles of light
right and shoots them in every direction
but the sun is is spinning and so is
every atom within the Sun so as soon as
it shoots one Photon the next one will
not go in the same direction not to
mention the whole series of them they'll
they'll curve around in space and here
let me show you a little bit of what
that might look like you know you got
the sun is just like a sprinkler it
shoots photons in every direction if
you're going to do this if you're going
to simulate this with particles okay
that's what's the nonsense is of doing
it with
particles okay so uh all I can tell you
is no uh particles do not travel in a
straight line it's impossible in the in
our universe so uh this Val is already
uh screwed up on the first one he said
uh you know particles travel in a
straight line absolutely not they cannot
possibly travel in a straight line
because everything in the universe is in
motion and especially you know the earth
the earth not only spins but goes around
the Sun so you can imagine uh if if we
do the if we simulate this with
particles you just shoot a beam right
let's assume it's made out of all these
particles right the beam and but the
Earth is moving and it's spinning and if
it come from from the Sun not to mention
every atom there is producing light you
know light photons particles of light
and they're coming towards you but the
sun is spinning and the atom is spinning
you know you can't get a straight line
no matter how you do it so no you can't
simulate light with particles it's
impossible okay we're going to get do a
little more today with this you can see
where we're going with all this okay uh
so here we have F said continues he says
the more you get near the spot where the
incident Rays reflected angle becomes
zero the reflected rays are now directed
towards the screen so if we do it with a
needle right like we're proposing here
and that's what he's criticizing he's
saying that uh light is reflected off
the needle in every direction but as
soon as you get there to the North Pole
or the South Pole right as you see at
the bottom uh he says well at that point
the Rays go straight to the screen so
far so good we have no no problem there
so far okay you can say that it doesn't
even touch the needle just goes straight
okay so can't even produce a shadow
unless it hits the needle okay but if it
hits the me needle there's no reason for
it to go straight okay so it either hits
at the the last atom there in the North
Pole uh and bounces somewhere or you
know it goes right through it in which
case he's got to explain why it goes
right through that atom okay so he's got
to explain that that detail to us but he
says but due to the surface being curved
what we observe is that the Rays and
notice that he talks about Rays there's
no such thing as a ray but he's going to
talk about Ray because it's a convenient
word people understand by the word Ray a
physical object they think light is a
physical object then they treat it as an
abstract concept as a flow of particles
which is not AR Ray so uh you know we
have to be careful about the word Ray
there so says uh that the Rays reflected
many different angles according to what
the law of reflection okay I don't know
what law he maybe was a lawyer maybe
went to a monastery to study we have no
laws in physics okay laws are in the
religion of mathematical physics not in
physics in science we don't have laws in
science we have to explain a mechanism
so there are no laws the laws means they
shoved it down your throat you must
follow it you must obey it means you had
to memorize it and you know repeat it
for your to get your grade he says each
reflected ray right again talking about
Ray is making a new DOT on the screen
well yeah but again either either you
hit the North Pole or you don't that
atom there if you hit it it's going to
bounce it's not going to go to the
screen if it goes right through because
it didn't hit it then uh you don't get a
shadow you don't you just get the light
directly okay and but the issue here is
going to be that blue the blue arrows
and we're going to see that in a second
here let me show you this this is the
issue here he says oh first let me
Define Ray just in case because uh this
guy uses the word Ray but hasn't defined
it so I'll Define it for him he can
always contradict me and Define it
differently says any of the lines of
light that radiate from a bright object
a beam of radiant energy such as light a
stream of material particles traveling
in the same line and a single particle
of such a stream and so the problem is
we don't know what array is could be any
of the above and essentially I think
what this follow is saying is that array
is a um a series of particles that are
traveling in straight lines which is
impossible if everything in the Universe
moves so uh we don't have such a
straight line in reality you know the
fact that these people are uh fooled
into believing that a string of
particles discrete
particles uh meaning that they're not
touching each other right it's just one
right after another like a bunch of
balls they cannot travel ever it's
impossible to travel in a straight line
what they call straight line meaning
rectilinearly okay that's the correct
word they cannot travel rectilinearly
one will be here the other one next
there and you'll see what you'll see
over time is a curve that's what it's
describing in in space right in as we
move around and they don't understand
that they say oh but the beam went
straight yeah then it can't be made of
particles because if it was made of
particles you would have a curve no
matter what okay you cannot
conceptualize a straight itinerary as
it's you know rectilinear itinerary with
discrete particles not in real life the
earth move the Earth spins the sun moves
every atom moves can't you can't achieve
it conceptually it's impossible okay and
so here he finishes up saying at 0 deg
this is the part I like the most is that
most of the light is pointing straight
and making the central Maxima no
absolutely not okay because he he's
thinking that this thing this needle is
transparent or something or translucent
no no the needle's going to block the
light so you're not going to get the
central Maxima which is that uh heavy
light that you get during the slute
experiment right in the center you're
not going to get it because the needle
was blocking all the particles there
that you see between the North and South
Pole so that's not true at all what he
said there but then he continues with
the word Rays he says some rays are also
deflected or defract
inwards contributing to the central
Maxima absolutely not he's saying that
there are particles that turn the corner
where you see the Red Arrows there how
does he explain that how did they turn
the corner that's the whole issue the
issue is that you cannot explain those
red lines with particles and then he
just summarizes as deflections explain
heading of light around corners
absolutely not so you know this guy
hasn't explained anything first of all
he's describing he doesn't understand
the difference between an explanation
and a description that's the first part
and then he's absolutely wrong he's he's
got he's I don't know where he got this
you know I want him to do this in the
lab show me with a bunch of balls right
particles he can throw sand if he wants
with a sand blaster or whatever and he
can go in there and show me how they
turn the corner Move inwards Like You
see there okay so so no this doesn't
happen the red lines the Red Arrows
there that's what he's explain he's
describing really he's not explaining
anything he's not telling us why they
turn the corner and he just says well
it's the law of reflection or refraction
or defraction or who knows what law he
learned out there now this is absolute
papika what he's pointing out there none
of it
holds even in a lab experiment everybody
can do it just put a telephone poll and
show me how the balls go inwards to show
it proof
evidence okay so yeah that's that's the
whole problem there okay but what what's
interesting about this whole thing is
that
um the word mass has not appeared yet so
so they're explaining the bending of
light from a light source for example a
laser turning around the corners of a
needle and they're doing it without mass
they're not saying that the mass of the
needle is bending light they don't use
mass at all here you know mass is not
part of quantum mechanics they don't use
the word mass at all there they use the
word energy yeah another form of mass
suppos they use charge you know plus
minus all this nonsense field but they
don't don't you or Force right uh but
they don't use mass and they don't
really do much on time either they don't
use the word time mass and time belong
to general relativity okay so when
they're out there you know with the
satellites and the uh um what is it the
uh celestial objects then they talk
about mass and they forget completely
about the slit experiment which also
supposedly bends light you know if we're
talking about photons discret photons
you know bends really
what did we say the other day it
deflects because you can't say you bend
light if light is made of photons of
discrete particles no the best you can
do is say that it
deflects the series of uh photons but
see they talk about bending Rays bending
light that's when they put the word Ray
and the word light because they're going
to bend light you know and so we have a
little problem there because if this Ray
this light is made of photons then bend
warp you know those are the wrong curved
those are the wrong words wrong verbs
but or or adjectives if you're going to
qualify it no what we're talking about
is deflection you're deflecting a beam
okay or a bunch of photons a series of
photon then you can say all these little
balls are being deflected then we
understand but you can't say bent but
they use the bend the word Bend because
they're going to talk about light and
other elongated objects which they treat
as
objects Concepts which they treat as
objects okay so here's uh just so that
you see what I'm talking about um that I
didn't invent all this stuff we want to
make sure that uh mathematical physics
does absolutely state that uh Mass bends
light okay this I didn't I did not
invent this stuff okay so it says how
does gravity affect photons that is bend
light right if photons have no Mass so
it's a question of mass bending light
okay and this comes from astronomy so
it's uh you can take this to the bank
okay they're saying well it is true that
photons have no Mass it is also true
that we see light bend around sources
with high mass due to gravity yeah we
see light bending as we saw just now
around needles and hopefully it's not
due to the mass or
gravity okay so we have the same
situation except instead of having the
Sun and the Earth and the far away you
know the distant star there what we have
is a needle we have the source of the
light which could be a laser and we on
the screen what what we see is fringes
so we bent light so to speak and we did
it without any Mass here they're going
to do it with mass so this is not
because the mass pulls on the photons
directly but instead because the mass
warps the
SpaceTime uh though which through which
the photons travel so what they're
saying is you know we're going to weigh
uh the canvas of space Town downwards
this is going to be the explanation this
is going to be the physical
interpretation we're going to bend it
down how we're going to put the sun
there we're going to weigh it down with
the sun the sun weighs this canvas
downwards so now the the path meaning
the route you know the highway right the
road the real physical road is bent it's
warped and so the photon has no choice
but the roll around or slide around this
curved surface okay so what's curved is
the surface light is not curved or bent
light is deflected because it's made out
of discrete photons which are rolling or
sliding around a curved surface so we
have to understand the context but these
people keep mixing all this up talking
about Ray
talking about paths right and there they
clarify imagine a bowling ball on a
mattress the ball is a massive object
say the sun right and the mass and the
mattress represents SpaceTime okay so
they're talking about physical objects
either even though SpaceTime is just a
what four number lines which they call
coordinates or Dimensions now it's
neither it's just a bunch of number
lines four number lines in which it sits
of course SpaceTime is four-dimensional
absolutely not it's four four number
lined that's what it is but it's a bit
harder to imagine that yeah tell me
about it you can't imagine four uh
number lines first being at 90 degrees
to each other because number lines have
no Direction you cannot put directions
to numbers you know they always put this
arrow in the coordinate system uh where
the arrow points in a given direction is
a 90 degrees to another that's not true
in number lines number lines they have
no direction and they are not they don't
run perpendicular to anything you can
put numbers in any direction you want
okay you can put them in s form if you
want okay so that's not true and that's
why he's got problems illustrating that
or visualizing or imagining it right
when you place the bowling ball on the
mattress it deforms the surface okay we
understand that if a grid were drawn on
the mattress you would see the grid
deformed so the straight lines of the bo
of the boxes were no longer straight
okay no problem we understand that the
same is true for a star sitting in
SpaceTime the star deforms SpaceTime
around it causing it to curve towards
the star meaning that not only SpaceTime
is a physical object according to this
description but it is malleable okay
it's
stretchy it's uh it's like rubber bands
you know it warps at your leisure now
imagine a marble this represents a
photon you rolled a marble in a straight
line on the mattress and it comes too
close to the bowling ball the marble
will curve because the mattress is
traveling on dips and curves around the
bowling ball this is what happens to
light traveling through space it dips I
guess all these see they talk about
light when they should be traveling
talking about photons but see at that
point they talk about rays and light and
path okay traveling through space when
it comes too close to um massive object
it encounters wi SpaceTime and curves
not because it's being pulled by gravity
see is says it curves instead of saying
it's deflected right but because the
SpaceTime it's traveling through is
curved yeah the space time might be
curved in your language but uh you can't
say the light is curved light is being
deflected because SpaceTime is curved
that's the way it should be said stated
right so it straight path becomes a
curved bent one no it's a the path now
they're talking about again path they're
saying it's a not the itinerary they're
saying the road the highway okay okay
and that's where the problem is they
they a mathematician is a person who
doesn't know how to talk so they use
adjectives when they're should be using
adverbs and they use nouns when they're
talking about verbs that's the problem
and their
language okay so where do we go from
here just to mention uh just wanted to
mention this that not only Mass
produces bent light okay they also Bend
and warp and curve light
with acceleration okay this is another
one okay and this came out of Einstein's
head had to be out of his head you know
this great scientist right physicist and
he said if you have zero motion inside
an elevator and you point a flashlight
you know from the outside the light goes
right straight through okay we
understand that if it's in a constant
velocity the two fellows moving at the
same time you have this light uh going
across well again it looks like we have
a straight line okay but if you have
acceleration the light
bends why it should I guess uh in
mathematical physics because it's made
out of photons right so be careful when
you accelerate always keep a constant
velocity for otherwise you're bending
light all these photons they make a
curve through space okay and yeah so
they have contradictions because on the
one hand here you have acceleration
producing the curvature of light meaning
the deflection of light okay but not
when you have a constant
speed uh their words okay just in case
yeah um incredible but this is what
these people who study 10 years at the
University tell you okay phds or what
was it dhps right dogghouse parrots
that's what they are they just parot
what they were taught at the dogghouse
so they're not phds they're d
HPS okay so what they're saying
essentially is the following uh because
of it because see because of uh what
these folks discovered that uh light
bends and so on uh and that there's this
warpage of SpaceTime they abandon Newton
and they abandon Newton only because of
a question of accuracy Einstein's
equation gives better numbers closer
numbers to reality than Newton so they
abandon all Newton all together and
partly because Newton could not explain
the mechanism the cause he said it's all
made of particles how does the sun
attract the Earth you know gravity with
particles you throw particles out how do
you attract something by throwing stones
at it you know what you need is a rubber
band you need a I don't know a a wire
some elongated object then you can pull
then you can explain gravity but if
you're throwing stones you can cannot
explain how you attracted the donkey you
need to put a rope around the donkey's
head then you can attract him that was
the problem and so here's Newton you
know um this was comes from the cosmic
times uh which was published uh in
1919 and uh this is out of NASA's
website okay and says the first the
following says that Newton in Optics he
said the say said the following or meant
the following a ray of light from a
distant star just grazing across the
edge of a massive object should be bent
okay ray being bent okay that's what
they're using the words by an amount
that depends on the object's mass and
thus its gravitational field field what
is field concept so we have concept
bending things Newton thought of gravity
is a force that pulls things towards an
object the bigger the object the
stronger the pull and then what was the
issue the issue was a question of
accuracy in the case of Newton he
applied his equation mass mass distance
squared right a light Ray from a distant
star grazing the edge of the sun would
should be attracted or bent by the Sun's
gravity by an amount equal to 0.87
seconds of Arc okay these are uh
astronomical measurements okay we don't
need to know exactly what they mean at
least not today we're not going to spend
time on determining what they are but
when uh einan came around he came up
with a different notion of what uh it's
uh gravity is supposed to be and he came
in the same Cosmic times there and they
said according to Einstein gravity like
in like inertia doesn't pull instead a
mass warps or Curves space and time
surrounding the object okay what we just
saw the sun weighing down SpaceTime the
amount of curvature is proportional to
the amount of mass the curvature of
space then curves of paths path uh what
are we talking about here path is that a
road is that an itinerary a trajectory
what are we talking about the paths
taken by Rays what's a ray this stick is
it a stick uh rays of light so we have
the path and the Rays okay and that's
what these people talk about they talk
about you know bending Rays bending the
paths of rays and it says Dr Einstein's
theory which is highly mathematical yeah
in other words has nothing to do with
physics physics we do not use math
physics is about explaining mechanisms
not about doing equations predicts that
the curvature of space around the sun
should bend Starlight by twice as much
as Newton's theory predicts and here is
1.75 seconds of art the other guy was
0.087 right thus Dr Einstein predicts
that a ray of light from a distance star
grazing the edge of the sun on its way
to the Earth would suffer twice the
deflections predicted by Newtonian
principles so because he was more
accurate right here it's says the amount
of by which uh Starlight deflected is
deflected by the sun is thus regarded by
astronomers and physicists mathematical
physicist all of them really not one of
them is a physicist or astronomer as one
of the crucial tests in determining the
validity of the Dr Einstein theory of
relativity versus Newtonian physics in
other words the the fight between
Einstein and Newton was an issue of um
accuracy okay so uh these folks
essentially abandoned Newton which said
particles you know gravity is particles
but he couldn't explain it in fact he
says finger hypothesis he had no
clue that's what he was saying I have no
clue okay here you this is Newtonian
version okay he said the sun you know
sends particle or receives particles
from the earth and that's why the Earth
doesn't fly away and he could not
explain with particles he wrote to um uh
Bishop Bentley he said I have no idea
how gravity Works what the mechanism is
and he said that H but uh few hundred
years later came I he says I got a
different idea here it is this is what I
say I propose we have this uh canvas you
know length width and height we put the
Earth in there or the sun you can put
whichever and the moon just rolls around
forever so uh they changed one you know
the force for the bending of SpaceTime
which is a geometric Theory okay so one
is a force Theory which Einstein says it
ain't but it is anyways because you have
a force weighing down the canvas why
does the Earth or the Sun for that
matter weigh down the canvas if it's not
a force pushing it downwards and what is
downwards out there in space well we
don't know we haven't figured out we
haven't you know settle that issue
either so you have the Earth or the Sun
weighing can canvas downwards with a
force and then for some reason then we
have gravity which is just a geometry of
SpaceTime that's essentially what these
people are saying so we still have Force
we haven't gotten rid of force that's
the point okay okay so um just in case
we rub it in one more time here's from
fmy laab now fmy laab is uh you know one
of these uh accelerator outfits out
there near Chicago okay and here it is
uh can you bend light this what they say
so here we have uh confirmation we have
out in space light rays Bend what's a
ray well there you have Ray Ray Charles
I guess I don't know uh when passing
very near massive objects such as stars
and galaxies okay the presence of matter
pure space and the path the path of
light Ray I guess the yellow brick road
there you know I don't know what path is
path is an itinerary trajectory or a
road is it a Highway what is a path and
a path of a light Ray so they're talking
about the itinerary of a bunch of light
rays what are what are Rays made out of
particles discrete particles discrete
photons so we have the itinerary of
photons they call it a path of a light
Ray says will be deflected finding
someone that uses the right word
deflected as a result yeah they're
deflected if you're going to talk about
particles this process is called
gravitational lensing which we covered
last week because of its uh similarity
to the way normal lenses bend light rays
again go back to bend and arrays right
that passed through them Einstein
predicted prediction all these
astrologers predict they call themselves
scientist Einstein predicted that light
rays would be bent by the gravity of
massive objects okay there you see the
pigs on the bottom okay scientists
observed this effect soon after the
theory of general relativity was
published Einstein published in 1915 and
it was U Arthur Edington that confirmed
in 1919 right couple years later since
lenses bend light they bend light okay
since lenses bend light we called any
massive object that bends light raise a
gravitational lens by measuring the
bending scientists can determine the
mass of the object causing the bending
now this is interesting because that's
how they determine black holes and dark
matter because they use mass and they
say oh something is pulling you know on
something else you know why why is a
black hole so popular because you have
the mass of the black hole supposedly
you know this thing that is infinitely
heavy right and it's tugging on a star
that is far away and forcing it to orbit
around it or gobbles up its gas skin
okay and eats it
up okay by what me mechanism and they
say
mass mass is a concept M Concepts don't
have the ability to affect things and so
we have this massive black hole which is
a Zero Dimensional no size no shape
nothing it's got lots of mass even
though it crushed all matter out of
existence and mass is the quantity of
matter or measure of quantity of matter
it's got no matter no size but it's got
influence sounds like a
politician and so it's tugging on a star
far away okay and dark matter the same
thing you know why do stars at the edge
of a galaxy travel just as fast or
faster than the ones on the inside you
know Pluto it's like if Pluto traveled
faster than Mercury around the Sun and
that ain't the case you know Mercury is
closer by goes around very fast 88 days
is one orbit and the other guy tell you
is what 248 years so it's a little bit
different you know and out there in the
galaxy it's the other way around the
ones on the outside travel faster than
the ones on the inside and so what did
they have to do they said well it can
only be mass and gravity right so they
had to pour a lot of Mass on the outside
of the Galaxy to produce that effect
invisible Mass invisible matter and they
call it dark matter it's dark because
you can't see it you can't feel it you
know it's translucent because you can
see the galaxies in the background where
the dark matter is supposed to be so
they sprinkle all this dark matter
around the edges of the Galaxy to get
the equations right so they invented
this ghost called Dark Matter and that's
how they explain all this stuff if you
can call it an
explanation okay what's the problem with
all this let's let's get rid of it all
completely all this garbage coming out
of mathematical physics out of Cambridge
and Harvard and Stanford and MIT and all
the ivy league get rid of all of them
execute them all I saying I think they
should all be hanged okay because
they're committing a crime against
humanity these people when they give all
this stuff to the public and they say oh
we can explain all this because we're
just telling you what the mathematics
says absolutely not they have a
completely misconception of how the
universe works and let me let's let's
expose these people okay here we go
we're going to go with something called
the Cavendish torsion balance okay
Cavendish came up with this actually it
was someone else but he stole the trick
okay and so Cavendish um did this
experiment with the torsion balance it
looks more or less like this this is a
modern version and you might say well I
don't believe in what I see here bill
you can do it at home uh millions of
people have done this all right
thousands maybe uh lots of people have
done this okay so all you need to do is
come up the speed on it okay but here it
is more or less in slow motion but it's
uh speed it up because what happened
over a period of several minutes is
speed it up okay but you'll see what the
tors and balance does it pulls masses
together here on Earth we can do it here
in the living room okay here it goes
okay so what you see here you see
there's a uh string a little thread
holding up this uh torsion bounce you
could call it the the bounce there it's
got some weights and you have two uh
Bing balls heavy ele things uh on
opposite sides and you can see one is
attracting one side the other one's
attracting the other side okay and so
there you have it in fast motion okay a
very slow process okay this guy filmed
it okay not mine again just borrowing it
and other people have done the same
experiment okay so this is known as the
torsion balance cend dises torsion
balance if we want to give it to someone
okay you can see Mass attracts Mass now
how much does a bing ball weigh okay uh
I don't know a couple pounds what if you
put uh something that weighs you know
like a 100
tons okay that's keep that in mind for a
second okay we're going to do something
like that right now okay so let's take
this one out let's put this other one
okay the other issue is Ray
reversibility what is Ray reversibility
a lot of people are not aware okay and
again that's why light cannot be made of
particles cannot be mediated by
particles discrete particles okay
because of Ray reversibility it's
impossible simply you shine a light any
light you know against the wall or
through a prism or whatever and light
retraces its exact path light is two-way
not
oneway let me repeat that you send a
beam right send some light or whatever
if you want to talk about sending okay
it goes to the prism it curves or it
bends you could say right light bends
you can see it bending like a spoon when
you put in water right so it bends okay
but the point here is that light
retraces its exact
path okay not that it goes this way and
then comes through another road to the
same point no it retraces its exact
point its exact path okay trajectory
itinerary is the same okay it's called
Ray
reversibility very little known uh uh
phenomenon in uh Optics okay nobody uses
it but here it is I'm going to
illustrate it here light retraces its
exact path okay goes to the mirror right
through the prism and to the light goes
in both directions okay um I'm not going
to go into the details of how we know
this but if you move because you know
Earth moves around the the sun uh spins
atoms are moving all around you know and
so if this is made out of particles and
the Earth is moving like we show there
it's it's made out of particles and
everything is moving then the light
would not retrace its its path it's
itinerary it would go somewhere else
okay that's what we're showing there
okay and this is something that shows
that you can the ray reversibility shows
that you cannot use particles to
simulate um
light and the then you have
the the torsion balance okay why am I
bringing these two phenomena well-known
phenomena well established phenomena up
because of the following we're going to
take a light laser is that fine with you
we'll take a laser pointer right and we
point it at a mirror or at a some some
object okay so we mark it we say it's
always pointing at that when it's
straight
and now we're going to bring
over several
tons of Weights of matter whatever you
want will it bend the beam or will the
beam continue
straight you know into this thing that
you mark there so let me illustrate that
and it's got got to do with Ray re
reversibility and also with a torsion
balance okay here it is okay here's uh
so by the way that's Fermat's principal
least um path okay but here's the point
you you've got one kilometer you go to
the desert right you shine a laser to a
mirror okay and you mark a spot on the
mirror you can even
uh connect the mirror to the flashlight
so that you always have the same
distance the same everything okay and
now you bring in three 300 tons there
you put them you you line them up up
along the beam next to it will the beam
Bend as predicted by mathematical
physics okay because according to them
you put all these tons there well it's
going to warp space somewhat and that
amount of warpage is going to you know
twist or bend the the beam of light does
this happen well I'll bet you a billion
dollars it doesn't happen Okay you can
put all the tongue you can put a
mountain next to it okay you can do this
experiment in the desert and compared to
next to a mountain you should get the
same results always a straight line okay
uh because again it's not made out of
partic a beam is not made out of
particles it's made out of a rope okay
the mediator of light is a rope and that
rope is taught it's pulled straight and
here more or less uh if you can see this
hopefully uh put it closer there okay
it's uh there it is okay and my fists
you know they're the atoms okay here it
is there we go there we go okay so my
fists are the atom and there you have
this rope okay can connects them torsion
of this thing is light and at the same
time you have a mediator for Gravity
which is a force of
pull no SpaceTime no waves no
particles rope with that else you have